des tas de terre et de fumier déverser
des deux heures du matin à coignières et
un accès à la raffinerie rendu
impossible la fnsea et les jeunes
agriculteurs ont débuté cette nuit leur
bras de fer contre le gouvernement il
s'oppose à l'autorisation accordée à
total pour importés d'asie de l'huile de
palme pour eux ces livraisons promises
pour l'ouverture d'une nouvelle
raffinerie mettrait à mal la filière
française de biocarburants et ne
respecterait pas non plus les règles
environnementales
on a eu tellement de choses qui nous ont
été eux
qu'ils nous ont été reprochés au niveau
environnemental par les différents
gouvernements successifs
on s'y adapte systématiquement est
aujourd'hui en fait le gouvernement nous
fait un beau pied de nez matinale aussi
la réponse du ministre de l'agriculture
sur rtl stéphane travert indique que le
gouvernement ne reviendra pas sur
l'accord avec total pour lui ces
blocages sont illégaux depuis que
j'occupe ce ministère nous avons
toujours été dans une étroite
concertation dans le dialogue
mais ce dialogue il doit être franc moi
je dis qu'aujourd'hui ces blocages sont
sont illégaux et que ce n'est pas en
bloquant des raffineries que l'on
trouvera les solutions adéquates tout
simplement sujet environnemental
sensible au sein même de la majorité
il y a une dizaine de jours le député
yvelinois bruno myle yens interpellé
l'exécutif sur le sujet comment serions
nous pour nous poser en leader mondial
de la cause environnementale et en même
temps favoriser de telles importations
la fnsea et les jeunes agriculteurs
prévoit pour le moment un blocage des
raffineries pour trois jours mais menace
déjà le mouvement sera reconduit
jusqu'au recul du gouvernement
un rendez vous est prévu demain au
ministère de l'agriculture